the last time you guys were here i was
talking about the foo fighters and who
is going to
put you into the rock roll hall of fame
and dave you said i got someone but i
don't want to say it here i want it to
be a surprise and blah blah blah blah
and then it turned out you got paul
mccartney to induct you into the rock
roll hall of fame which you really can't
do better than that how does it come
about do you call him and say paul
please do this
uh or do you have somebody else do it
i'd be too embarrassed to ask myself
yeah we didn't call him personally i
think somebody else did it but we know
him i mean you know he's a really sweet
guy and we've known him for a long time
so i think
he uh agreed to do it because he wanted
to do it for us because we're friends
but um we didn't make the personal call
no yeah because that would have been
awkward that would have been weird right
and you don't give him any kind of uh
guidelines about what to say you don't
feed him any information whatever he
says he says and that's it paul okay now
come here
get over here paul no no come here
here's what you're going to do here's
what you're going to say and you're
going to [ __ ] say this
jesus
no i thought it was neat the way he did
the speech and he sort of
made the parallels between dave bing and
nirvana and that being this crazy
tornado
and then out of that dave found his way
to the foo fighters and we slowly kind
of made our way
up and he said it's sort of a similar
story like the wings
from the beatles and i've i always kind
of thought of us like the wings a little
bit
i don't know you've said it on the show
you've said it you've said it on our
show that that you guys are the wings of
grunge
yeah and i was kidding but i know but it
was a funny line it was a good line
probably you said it on this show yeah
well
i would think dave's songwriting in the
wing stuff is similar i mean it's it's
it's good song structures and and it's a
new i mean you know for dave to come out
of nirvana and have something as
successful as it is i mean most people
just don't get a second act like that
you know they don't they don't i've said
that to dave
dave's dave said no there have been
bands who do it you know clapton uh of
course went to uh cream but nirvana was
so big and paul was right dave it was a
solid it's funny i didn't i never really
considered any of that stuff like as
focused as what he was saying
you know apparently i did
taylor put a lot of thought into this i
think taylor wrote the [ __ ] speech
for paul yeah paul get over here man get
over here
i got something i thought it was very
magnanimous of you in your rock and roll
hall of fame acceptance speech you
lobbied for the following people to be
in the rock and roll hall of fame george
michael jane's addiction boy were you
right on with jane's addiction come on
and sound garden of course
i mean yeah you have to remember dude if
you remember back in 1988 89
when uh jane's came out and then and
then soundgarden not soon after
um that was like a real like oh man
there's gonna be good rock music because
it was getting to that point where rock
music was kind of not it's like i liked
being handling an early rat but it was
getting kind of
like what what's gonna is there gonna be
something good coming and as soon as you
heard jane's addiction
and as soon as you're at soundgarden
you're like yes there is there's rob on
the horizon
it was a seismic shift in the way music
was uh being produced and heard it was
absolutely it was getting gutsy and
interesting and
you know not just about partying or
whatever
um and then george michael
i just think that guy's got the best
voice
of all well
no offense to george michael jethro tull
before george michael i i don't
understand that one no that's pretty
trippy yeah i think king crimson should
be in ian mcdonald died this week
let me let me honor them
king in the card of the crimson
[Music]
love that
petals
you